carte de séjour depuis sept ans ils font
de la musique
aujourd'hui rien n'a changé ou plutôt si
on parle d'eux première reconnaissance
officielle le bus d'acier un grand prix
du rock qu'ont déjà obtenus il y a
quelques années bat chou ou etienne daho
et puis ce matin la reconnaissance
officielle lyonnaise pour un groupe qui
n'a toujours pas sa langue dans sa poche
il est utile de se rappeler gentil
migrants qui contribue à l'expression
culturelle et mons des petits fours
qu'on va manger tout à l'heure dans les
salons lambrissés d'administration et
les méchants les grecs qui se sont fait
tabasser car ils ne font qu'apporter
leur force de travail alors pays
d'adoption
scherwiller de mon enfance nous met en
confiance
jetez y avait dans mon coeur
ce prêt durant que ce bus dassier c'est
la consécration
je pense que c'est comme quand même 10
assists a été lancée des gens qui votent
et donc de milieux ruraux et tout donc
je pense que c'est consacrer sans
critique d'abord montré après bon ce qui
est intéressant c'est la suisse est à
dire qu'il ya beaucoup de l'argile au
public tout ce qui vous permet ce qui
permet d'être plus court samedi prochain
carte de séjour sera au printemps de
bourges le groupe chantera avec un
invité de marque charles trenet
ma prairies et ma maison tout le monde
cher pays de mon enfance
temps des sciences
haarde et dans mon coeur
mon village
au clocher on est otage tous les
comprendre pour la partager mon bonheur
pour notre
pourri je t'aime et je donne ce fonds
est pourri je t'aime dans la joie nous
prend cher pays de mon enfance le temps
des solutions je les garde en mon coeur
nous prend
de france